welcome to this video jaguar jaguar I'm
lucky I me come on give me a movie for
let's do the calc on I haven't played
this for some time this it feels like
that okay maybe the part of know the
exchange alley exchanges an old favorite
of bobby fischer's at the time he had a
pretty decent results with that winning
a a very well-known game against the
chosen with this opening but pitocin
plated them really not very precise the
screen c7 ism is some an improvement on
what Petrosian played just a little
improvements nothing the grade okay I'm
going to go for this stratum Bishop f5
this some double pond construction is
not really a problem for black it's a
very stable structure and if I get in 94
I really like my position so that's
interesting okay I don't want to take
him rook takes 94 will the probably win
material and here i mean here this looks
like this pawn is slightly isolated the
e5 pawn I mean it looks looks more like
a weakness um yeah if I how do i take
this actually i take it with this listen
it is interesting yeah it's a it's a
weird structure but i might have rook
the 83 at some point if you place bishop
f6 i'm just taking a limp like when you
hire winning the
on he can play a three but it's still
it's still an important pawn okay I'm
not winning the porn but i'm getting a
very nice endgame yeah ok maybe look III
g3 is something okay it's not going for
that at all
it's IDM is to take on CH and play d 5
okay i hope what i'm thinking is right
if it takes takes d5 roop d8d six I can
just packing at seven and you cannot
take on e6 or any anywhere tag tag he's
preparing this this caption if i take
now and play rook to d7 check box e8
king at seven rook e8 King g6 rookie 7
i'm taking default XP 7 hmm tough I'm
not sure really so this move on I can
also go there immediately yeah maybe I
can go to before right I can go to be on
in case of recon c7 at least sometimes
so this a 5 or this I will win anyway I
guess a five possibly a fourth what I'm
hoping is that my advanced pawns f porn
f5 and you for that was later f43 i will
get a dangerous pass porn this is what
I'm what I'm thinking okay I can play a
for now which is interesting
that's interesting right let's try that
that's a gives me really dangerous pawns
rock t 2 there's some quite a threat now
it's a difficult position for wild what
is this idea h5 I don't really get it
don't don't really get it to be honest
ok this is this is what I do anyway here
yes to play king g one now and this is
certainly not what you wanted to have
but I don't I don't have a great reply I
probably will just take f6 I think I
don't have any tactic or or something
drastic like f3 move like that it's not
helping me much I don't threaten OOP you
one check King edge looking everyone you
can always go to g3 now Chad III and no
this is this must be winning for black
it's not going to work so III or is this
is III now the pawns will promote on
their own don't need the king
White Rose I know if you lost is really
quickly which wasn't necessary i think
black is clearly better here anyway but
it kingi one is it's really mandatory
okay the computers on minus three so
it's it's already a fast first issue I
was pretty confident than I should be
winning but still yeah it's simply I
mean I can't I can just use the pawns
him he really has not not much that you
can do let's say what can you do check
check say here yeah and I'm just just
entering here as mentioned those pawns
are very dangerous I think that g4 was
was really a really a mistake but ah
yeah I think he's in trouble the
computer is on 1-2 year already I mean
I'm winning this porn and I'm one pawn
up and this this pawn mass is very
dangerous it's simply like that while he
does not have much on the queenside said
I was surprised that it was so good I
was thinking it should be good for black
but it is really really almost almost
winning okay thanks for watching